all right he is the 2017 nfl coach of
the year 2018 nfc champion head coach
sean mcveigh already two years down and
starting year three as an nfl head coach
welcome back to the program buddy how
are you thanks it's me it's been a while
mike it's been hard hard-hitting
i'm a little disappointed i mean you
know the power rankings in the nfc west
they've been thrown out of whack you
know that i mean you're no longer the
best looking coach in the nfc west coast
kingsbury is the new title holder i
think i'm putting you with two and i'm
putting kyle at three
i mean peter says
you win the muscle awards so i'll beat
him up then you'll beat them up for sure
there's no doubt about that i love it
how are you feeling after two years of
doing this job now because the sense is
you're gonna do it for like 40 more
years no chance
i feel i feel good you know it's funny
actually because i would say that this
year i felt better than i did after the
first year and i think a lot of that is
all right how can you on have a
legitimate understanding of how
important that sleep is and being more
efficient with your time and how you
maximize every single day um you know
certainly the season is a grind but love
this to say that i'll be doing that for
40 more years that means that i you know
that i'm still coaching if i'm still
doing this 40 years from now i will be
shocked but seriously you look at guys
like belichick and carol right 66 66-67
and they've been doing it all this time
i mean i know i look at i say you know
what he's i'm going to be dead and he's
still going to be coaching i mean do you
look at them and say that's what i want
to do i want to still be doing it when
i'm that age i think what i have more
than anything is is such a respect that
they've been able to sustain and do it
so so well at such a high level for so
long you know because it is a grind i
mean you know the mental toll and i
think every single year hopefully
provides an opportunity to be more
efficient uh you know surround yourself
with great people which we've been able
to do in these first two years but um i
wouldn't say that i look at it like that
i think there's more of just an
admiration for their sustainability and
how long they've been able to do it i
mean wade's the same way i mean you look
at the production for what wade's been
able to do for so long but i know i love
it right now but if i don't figure out
how to start balancing it out and
getting a little bit more sleep i'm
probably going to burn myself out
with the balance like how do you you
know how do you do it how do you stay in
shape what what what is it how many
hours a night of sleep per night you
know where what kind of music how do you
check out what do you do that's a good
question and i think the biggest thing
from a sleep standpoint early on in the
week you know it's anywhere between you
know four four and a half hours monday
tuesday wednesday thursday but i try to
be really mindful and this is something
that i noticed a big difference because
i want to be sharp on sunday sure is two
days out really those fridays and
saturday nights trying to really at
least get eight hours of sleep right
right and and you know it's not
necessarily eight straight it's any sort
of accumulation and that was really
beneficial you might take a nap is what
you're saying yeah yeah absolutely good
for you and that's something that that i
think i definitely felt a difference
just in terms of you know how you know
your focus your concentration how quick
you're able to be some of the decisions
that you inevitably have to make on
sundays and then even just popping in
for 10 to 15 minutes right after
practice or right before and doing a
quick little you know cardio or
something just get a sweat going
absolutely so um you know those are
things that have been helpful but i also
think just being more efficient where
you kind of know some of the things that
you're inevitably going to have to
navigate in that role that you know you
have no idea until you get into it yeah
and and being able to lean on people but
then having a better idea going into
year two where you're able to
self-reflect i think was a little bit
more helpful when your head hits the
pillow are you a guy that it takes a
while to decompress and fall asleep or
are you right out you know it depends i
i usually hit it pretty quick but then i
usually i'm waking up sweat and dreaming
about you know whatever defensive
pressure double coverage or something
right yeah exactly but uh no i sleep
pretty well and and you know but i am uh
you know but instead of that and that
internal clock goes off pretty early in
the morning but but i get tired pretty
pretty uh early as well do you have like
crazy dreams where you're like because i
know that i'll have like dreams like i'm
late for the show for example like i was
today
but now let's not talk about that but
do you ever ever like weird dreams like
you're coaching a game and there's like
aliens landing i mean just like we all
have those misfiled dreams you're i just
did not have a helmet going out to like
the field really yeah i still have that
dream even though i'm not playing
anymore you know i i have had some
dreams you know i had a dream i can't
remember who it was but there was a
media reporter that i actually was
playing i forced a fumble and picked it
up and ran it for a touchdown in the
super bowl leading into the game you
know i think it might have been you
chris
but i i'll tell you what is more likely
to happen with coaches is you get later
on in the week you take a nap it's on
like friday because that's usually the
day that you get out a little bit
earlier right and this has happened to
me multiple times where you'll fall
asleep on your couch
maybe at let's just say it's five and
you wake up at 7 30 at night oh my gosh
it's the next day i always don't know
where you're right and you get up i mean
i've heard of coaches that have actually
gotten into their car and started
driving to work in those types of
situations right usually mine is about a
two minute panic where i'm running
around before uh veronica looks at me
and says what's wrong with you it's
friday night yeah that's always the
worst feeling though when you wake up
from a nap you wake up in the middle of
the night like where am i what am i
doing where am i supposed to be yeah it
is it's a bad one it's part of the
football culture how about like right
now i mean do you feel like you're in
catch-up mode you know going into the
super bowl as far as free agency draft
yeah we're definitely behind you know
but i think that as long as we don't try
to rush through things uh just being
efficient maximizing those days but
you're definitely way behind in terms of
your scheme evaluation yeah you know i
really haven't had a chance to dive into
a lot of these guys just draft wise and
so much of that is predicated on what's
the feel of our team the guys that we
want to resign yeah then how do you
always project not only the 90 but being
mindful 53 and then also what's your
projected 46. right you know so a lot of
those things play into it but we're
definitely behind that's why you're
excited about you know kind of doing
some things in the meantime where you
know you like doing this you know this
is what's great about our jobs we love
this sure studying players studying
other teams studying ourselves is
something that we're excited about but
it is something we're going to have to
be a little bit more efficient and
probably have a little bit longer days
early on in the off season than we're
accustomed does it give you more
appreciation for i know you got
appreciation for the marty but for new
england and how they've been able to do
this yeah it's incredible yeah you know
that's the one thing chris that you know
and i know you have a respect for them
but but you know people say after that
game oh you get back and he's like no
you don't get it if you just think that
because it's so hard and there's so many
things that the year entails and that's
why you got to enjoy one day at a time
the off season and for them to just be
able to reset the way that bill is able
to keep everybody focused never allow
the complacency to set in it's
unparalleled i mean it's it's incredible
it really is we give you one mulligan
from the super bowl we and we've
resisted talking about the superbowl
you know you talk about it all the time
but one thing that you could do over
from that game what would it be
well you know i i don't here's what i
would say to that there's a lot of
things i think the biggest thing that
you you try to do is okay when you're
specifically a play caller it's you want
to have a feel for the flow of the game
and obviously
early on they've clearly declared that
in the early downs they were going to
play a front structure and more of a
quarters principle game where they were
topping it down that was something that
that we had a feel for early on but what
i would do differently is make sure that
you're putting your players in a
position the way that you practice and
prepare to have an ownership for some of
the things that we activated so it's one
thing to call a play yeah
as a coach it's easy to say well you're
calling something for quarters coverage
and we didn't do this that's an excuse
you got to make sure that you're putting
your players in a position to have the
ownership and so i think with the way
that you prepare having a better
contingency plan knowing that yeah they
put a lot of man coverage on tape but
let's make sure you got a better
all-purpose menu some different things
that we can activate that give jared or
other players a better chance to you
know have success and that's what i
would do leading up to it so that they
kind of understood and had a better feel
for the intent of some of the calls can
you give us an example of one situation
where that may have had if it had been
yeah like i look at it like like the
fifth play of the game you know we were
calling a play versus quarters where we
had cooks leaning out you know not the
one that everybody talks about where he
was in the end zone where there's
another one the first time you called it
he was even better to look for there was
that one you know because mccoy didn't
replace you know playing a quarters
principle the safety jumped robert woods
coming on the high cross and in a lot of
instances cooks was leaning out with
gilmore on his outside half and taking
it across and if mccourty doesn't back
up you know that's where you've seen
jared he'll come out of his out of that
drop and immediately his eyes are big
down the field and he's launching that
on one hitch
and i feel like if i had done a better
job echoing and articulating the intent
knowing hey i'm calling this one because
we're expecting quarters this is what
they're doing different than what the
week of preparation entailed right i
think that he probably makes that play
or we give ourselves a chance to you
know and they did such a great job you
don't want to take you know away the
credit the patriots yeah yeah we did a
great job but to me i think it's it's
one thing to say oh well and you know
chris we're calling the play for this
but did we really put the players in a
position to know the intent right the
mechanics and then be able to problem
solve or execute it and know here's what
we're thinking right yeah and you know
when people hear that they think well
why didn't you talk about a lot of stuff
everything you have to do even with two
weeks to get ready there may be for all
it takes is one play where it wasn't
communicated the way that you wanted
because there's only so many hours sure
there's only so much you can cram into
the guys that that's the you know that's
where it just all kind of lines up and
manifests itself yeah and the reason i
say that play too is because
if you're able to hit that right and
make them pay then i think it forces
them to make some adjustments where we
never really made them pay so they were
able to just kind of play that
consistent front structure coverage
structure on the normal down and
distances and then they were really able
to dictate it as opposed to you know
what we want to try to do offensively
yeah never scared them yeah we never we
never made them pay for that and and and
you know we had another we had some
chances but ultimately i could have done
a much better job but that one play if
you said one i mean i could think of
about 30 in the game but that one stands
out because it's that early in the game
and then you hopefully think that it
affects and alters you know the way that
they have to adjust and adapt to us as
opposed to us trying to make them pay
and you know weren't able to do that as
a result of a lot of things that you
know me not putting our players in the
right spots you're kid genius like we i
he makes money right now
that's pretty good i like that i like
that that's very very good there um but
i am always amazed about you and
everything your you know your approach
the way you conduct yourself on a daily
basis uh also just your appearance which
matters like and i know this might sound
silly do you have like a barber who
comes to the facility or you do go to a
barber do you go to a hair stylist that
means a lot you know i i do think she
does nice job with my hair she does so
you got a smoking hot girlfriend no just
reach back that way i mean you're doing
a good
[Laughter]
you know what it is uh i do have a show
the barber will sometimes come to the
facilities if need be or it's right by
us and uh you know i get a lot more
recognition because they're like who is
the dud with a freaking pretty chick
right there my girlfriend's got more
followers on instagram and i'm like
you know what i'll take it right right
right i'm a lucky man hey one of the
things the patriots have impressed us
with over the years their ability no
matter how the season ends with the
super bowl win with the super bowl loss
a loss in the playoffs they always find
a way to forget incredible everything
that happened and i'm sure that's easier
said than done what's the biggest
challenge from your perspective for you
coaching staff everyone players everyone
forget last year and focus on zero and
zero going forward i think you just said
it mike and it's a consistent approach
and and really it's that daily operation
and it's that complacency you never
allow it to set in i mean for them to
really go to three straight and then
lose it last year and be the only team
since 72 to come back and win it is is
unbelievable but i think what they do
such a great job of just from my
understanding from the outside in is
every year presents new challenges
there's a focus there's a concentration
on what they want to do to get better
the complacency never sets in but i
think one of the things that you'll hear
us talk about moving forward that really
helps keep me on track is you know you
want to learn from the past produce in
the present and prepare for the future
but people that say oh you're just going
to be right back you know that's not the
way to look at it at all yeah you came
up short in the super bowl but to even
put yourself in a position to compete
requires that one day at a time focus
and concentration and i think that's why
it's important to have people coaches
players that love football because then
you love the process that the year
entails whether it be the off-season
program training camp one game at a time
and putting yourself in a position to
hopefully win the opener all right you
got i mean you got some good problems to
have because you're so talented but how
do you how do you balance all of it
dante fowler and dominic and sue you
know kind of what's your approach here
yeah that's the biggest thing chris is
figuring out with our guys that are
going to be free how we prioritize that
within the framework of you know the
budget and the cap and a lot of that is
predicated on all right let's identify
those core pieces that are coming back
let's have a look at what does the draft
you know entail that's where you really
rely on less and those guys getting
ahead of us what does free agency look
like and then clearly we've explored the
trade avenues as a way to acquire
players you make a splash every year
yeah i mean and that's something that i
think is good where there's you know you
you never want to be able to shy away
from an opportunity to be aggressive if
we feel like it makes us better dante
fowler is a big guy that we want back
and he's an important part of it third
round yeah absolutely and i thought he
made a big difference for us you know
there's certain guys you just feel the
explosion uh you know he had two
game-winning plays for us when you look
at seattle where he forces the fumble to
look at new orleans where forces the
errant throw by drew john johnson makes
a great pick so he he impacted the game
i thought he played great super bowl he
was amazing
getting out on the back and coverage he
really was phenomenal he did a great job
in that we gotta let you run but real
quick still texting with belichick even
after the super bowl absolutely not
another one no you say congratulations
he's he's got better texts than i do
actually he's more likely to go eggplant
emoji or poop emoji
you know what
i don't think i can answer that but i
don't know enough about the emojis to
answer that
we got there we go congratulations that
was great we look forward to talking to
you again soon take care everybody
thanks man
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports